At this point, you should be familiar
with personas and wire frames.
Your next task is to create at
least one persona and a user flow.
You can lay out your persona
on a piece of paper like this,
split up into four quadrants.
Your persona should include
the following information.
A sketch of the person, or a picture of
the person, and their name, demographic
information, and any behaviors that you
think are relevant to your product.
Here you should include demographic
information that leads to specific
types of behaviors.
And here you should put their
pain points and their needs.
Try to differentiate personas around
pain points, needs, and their behaviors.
By designing your product for
their behaviors or
their different pain points and needs,
you could really target different users.
And finally here is where
your product comes into play,
this is where you put all
your solutions for that user.
You can create this persona using any
tool of your choice and I've included
some additional tools and examples which
are linked in the instructor notes.
You can rely on user research
here to help you out.
Remember the goal is to
create something quickly.
You can revisit this
persona that you create and
the user flow when you learn about
design sprints in lesson three.
Create a persona and
include a user flow that shows how
a user would complete a task, and
how the user would interact in the main
navigation or flows of your product.
You can see one example of this which
is linked to the instructor notes.